foreign
such a charm about him and a Charisma I
would be Rebecca because I think her
character itself is such a mysterious
character such a badass and of course I
would be Genji
either Haley or Rebecca because honestly
I think those two women are just so cool
and they are to me
sophious they're also like sisters to me
off the top I was going to say Paul
Plymouth because her character's
freaking nuts oh TC without a doubt you
know I just get it on I go out cause
some trouble break the law a couple of
times do some ridiculous you know run
naked through Times Square and then give
them a call and say hey there's going to
be some people calling